magic everything that exists everything
that humans have created started out in
someone's imagination we have the power
to change the world with our minds and
our thoughts Michael run in your mind
please imagine that you're reaching into
your vial and pulling out the card
you're thinking of imagine turning it
face up and sliding it right back into
the center of the file you're thinking
of a card here in the blue power in
which clock what card are you thinking
out you want me to tell us please queen
of clubs because of the power of your
imagination and the power of imagination
to changed the world around us the queen
of clubs is the one in the blue pile
that jumps out and turn huh I think you
haven't touched it yet I didn't do that
you did that
but Michael you're thinking of a card
here in the red pile which one are you
thinking afraid of folks because of the
power of your imagination the Queen of
Hearts is the one in the red pile that
jumps out and turns face up but queen of
clubs you know that's the one that comes
Queen of Hearts guys you know that's the
one that comes from the blue yeah and I
have to say honestly the two of you did
such a fantastic job concentrating on
these particular cards the rest of them
you know those just sort of fade it away
everything working really hard in the
studio and I thought people could use a
little bit of a break so I invited my
friend Brian Markinson to come visit
hey Mego Frey is a wonderful magician
who performs the Magic Castle in
Hollywood California here and he's
excellent at card handling sleight of
hand all that good stuff and so I
figured enjoyed seeing our friends have
their minds blown a little bit pretty
great let's go see what happens hey
how's it going good I'm Brian let's me
chance me like magic Oh everybody does
man would you do me a favor Jay yeah
would you just reach in and take one of
those for me but don't let me see it
just quick take it out I don't want to
see you know what it is
yes excellent to make sure you remember
it please just keep saying the name of
it over and over again in your head okay
don't say it out loud though because
that would give it away right but in
your head keep repeating the name of the
card over and over right just keep
saying two of diamonds two of diamonds
diamonds two of diamonds two diamonds
over and over again you got it now that
way you won't forget us yeah was it what
what you have all right Wren that's
right name a card for me right anyone
you'd like in the deck yeah he's the
seven space any reason for the seven of
spades or is that literally just rare uh
actually shoot can you guys can you guys
help me find the seven of Spades in here
I'm looking for it I want to take it out
and do something with it ah sorry guys
uh I don't see it no it's got to be here
he just told me that right yeah right
yeah you just tell you that yeah you did
wait wait oh no no no I'm so sorry I
forgot it's my fault I'm sorry before I
start I always keep one card right here
in my pocket
yeah I actually really like the seven of
spades though you know it's a it's a
really good card um and if you don't
mind I'd like to try something else with
it with you right yeah and I would you
just gently touch one of the cards for
me but don't take it out that one right
there are you sure I choose that one
because you can change your mind if
you'd like but you don't have to I
choose to change my mind I'll keep
drawing this one this this time you're
sure that time I want to change again
let's change one word one more time okay
this one you don't want to change again
that's that's the one you changed twice
yes this is your third that's my third
choice Wren what card did you say a
second ago is at the 7 of Spades it's a
really good card I'm so glad you can't
you go to this one I don't know what I
was wanted to catch a card trick really
quick absolutely let's do something fun
Sam I'm gonna run through I'd like you
to take one of the cards but don't let
me see her anyone it doesn't matter a
really good car that's a great one take
a look at it shorter onto everyone else
exam I'm just gonna go like I could to
say stop it at some point as I run
through okay stop put your card back
right okay that's good cuz here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna give the cards
some packs and some chocolates to make
sure that the one that you chose Sam is
lost somewhere in the deck right this
way no one knows where it is and only
you guys know what it is back there
no one's ever to find it yeah here's the
thing though and all of the cutting and
shuffling it's possible that your card
came up here to the top of the deck
wouldn't be magic though I mean it could
just be a coincidence right there's a
chance it's Posse would be magic Sam
tonic which is this your card on top the
five of clubs that's good mmm cuz I'm
not in the business of coincidence right
I want magic yeah uh Sam would you do me
a favor please
that's a little excellent would you
please take the five and just slide it
into the deck somewhere fun place
anywhere you play hold on to it though
just mark that place and don't let me
move it people always think I move it
because you could have put it anywhere
but you put it kind of near the top and
you put it right above that card Sam
would it be kind of cool if that was the
one who chose a moment ago it'll be kind
of cool what was it you can tell me
three of spades
you know what though still could be a
coincidence even if this was the three
of spades in fact the only way this
would be magic is if the three of spades
was in your hand
now that's real holding that the whole
time as real magic
let's do something that uses not cards
for a moment let's move on and try
something that uses some everyday
objects the rubber bands I need two
rubber bands somebody grab a rubber band
someone else grab a rubber band and take
a look at those make sure there's
nothing special about the rubber bands
my quality rubber bands right you can't
see the magnets no no I'm kidding
there's no magnets
people always think there's something
special about the rubber bands even
though there's not but they think there
is because what's about to happen is
impossible I mean can you guys see that
this rubber band that these rubber bands
here the way I have them on my fingers
that this one here is kind of on a
locked inside the other one you guys can
see that it's in there and that it can't
get out but if I rub you can actually
see it happen one strand at a time
yeah hey do it again one more time right
then right over here for me please would
you would you pull the rubber band like
this between your fingers for me boys
okay one finger only there you go come a
little bit closer to me because now if I
come on to this side of your rubber band
I apologize that you iPod chess you know
do you I don't know why you why you do
that but you know I just look for that
little soft spot
what's your name sir Spencer would you
come over here for later and I'm just
gonna run through would you take one of
these cards for me but don't let me see
it oh yeah go ahead and take it out take
a look at it show it to everyone else I
don't want to see and when you're ready
if you would just place that back right
there for me please
thank you so folks a while back I saw my
son and he was playing with a deck of
cards in part I think because you know
when you're a kid you want to emulate
with your parents do and I was playing
with cards quite a lot at that time and
I remember watching him as he was
practicing shuffling the cards but he
wasn't paying attention and I swear this
is true I'm not making this up honest to
God I was watching him as he was
shuffling but what he had done is he had
left some of the cards face-up and had
some of them facedown you guys ever seen
little kids do this before or they
actually mixed the cards so that they go
face up into face down it happens all
the time he actually did this where he
mixed the cards like that but face up
into face down and I honestly don't
think he realized what he had done until
he cut the cards and he saw right that
he had some cards that were face up in
the deck and some cards that were back
to back or face to back face to face
back to back just kind of mixed up all
the way through and he was actually a
bit upset and he turned to me he said
dad would you fix it for me please
you know I really think that he believed
that I could that I could just snap my
fingers and fix it just like that
because when you're a kid you don't know
how the world works and you believe that
your parents have all the power in the
world that they can do anything you know
I wanted to look up to that for my son I
wanted to be that guy and so I took
those cards that he'd mixed up like that
Spencer and I wanted to imagine what it
would be like if I could just snap my
fingers and fix it so I took them I
don't know you know I just I just
started to spread them right just to see
what it could look like if I could just
fix it
but a moment ago you selected a card and
imaginations not just for kids it's it's
for us too and if you don't mind I'd
like you to use yours can you try to
picture that card in your mind I mean
really see it
visualize imagine what it looks like
right you're trying to
see that's a surprise that one car here
in the Yaak give him a round of applause
he's got a half
there's always like you're so used to
seeing like you say systemic shows like
a crappy like school functions growing
up and like church function loss of an
NEC like the guy at the top of the game
driving Club not even close Veta you run
the people in every town they can like
impress a bunch of kids but when
everybody's growing up and jaded about
it and you can still like wow them yeah
it's pretty cool so okay so this is what
I'm gonna do and I'm gonna teach you a
trick but before I teach it I want to
show it to you first so that you get a
sense of the the feeling that you get
when you watch the trick performed
because I guarantee you after you know
how it's done
you're going to say that won't fool
anybody okay we're gonna start with the
9 and the 6 okay and not what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna put those in two
different places in the deck now can you
guys see that those are honestly and
truly going in two completely different
places in the deck just like that I'm
not holding any marks or anything I
thought they are in there this is a
regular it's a regular deck of cards
because this is what we're gonna do this
is where it gets interesting if I
concentrate I give a little bit of a
snap and a little bit of a toss just
like that I can pull two cards right out
thank you and so that is the trick was
that a good trick that was a great trick
it was a good trick it's a good trick as
soon as you know how it's done it's not
such a good trick but that's okay
because here's how it's done what I do
to begin with
is I show you these two cards the nine
of Hearts and the six of diamonds but I
don't call attention to that I just say
I'm going to show you a 6 and a 9 and I
have these other two cards already on
the top and bottom and forget I see so
now I say I'm going to show you I'm
going to use the 6 and the 9 and I don't
call out to just say 69 and now I do
something that's called time
misdirection I take my time as I'm
putting these cleanly into the debt
we're talking about it I wait at least
20 seconds maybe more before I do
anything else as I'm going through and
showing you and this is where you're
focused you've already forgotten even
though you were thinking about it which
suits those six and nine were and so now
all I have to do is dip a little bit of
a squeeze on the deck and if I squeeze
the deck just right and give it a toss I
can retain the top and the bottom part
and it just comes right off in the Mike
performance is most of magic in fact I
would venture to say that 95% of magic
is in the presentation and in the
performance how long have you been doing
this if I was five years old so this may
seem like an obvious question but why
don't miss ins want to reveal how they
do the trick because it's no fun it is
actually very very easy to learn how a
magician performed a trick the resources
are out there go to the library they
have literally hundreds of books on how
to perform magic at the library go to
Amazon card College by Roberto gob the
first book that I ever learned that I
ever got when I was five years old was
called magic with cards by Frank Garcia
and George Schindler it's literally two
cents on Amazon so I fully expect that a
couple of you guys watching these videos
will know exactly how these tricks are
done if you want to discuss it and all
that kind of stuff
by all means I'm not going to tell you
what to do but I'm just this is jest
that blatantly ruining the trick will
take away from the magic of it all
consider these
exactly what you want to reveal if you
do know the secrets now if you're trying
to help somebody or you're going to
discuss all the interesting ways and it
could have been done that's one thing
but consider the magician's code you're
fans of any particular magician or know
any really good YouTube videos on magic
and sleight of hand by all means share
those that'd be really cool to check out
the one of my favorite stories is when I
was in college I was walking down the
street at UC Berkeley and I was playing
with cards and some kids on the street
came up and said show me a trick so I I
did a trick for them I did the trick
that I did for Sam actually with a the
card changes in the hand and this kid
screamed at the top of his lungs through
the card onto the street and took off
running and man and didn't stop until I
couldn't see him so that was a peak
that's awesome and there were no visual
effects than any of this video throwing
it out there that's true this is the
same anikó channel we only do visual
effects that I'm involved Peter the
interns